This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners.
wherever you are in the world, thank you for joining us. Before we get into it, I have a really special, amazing announcement, something that has been in the works for some time. We have officially launched a Patreon for the Psychology of Your 20s. If you want some bonus content, if you want to see behind the scenes, if you want the episode transcripts, access to the studies that I use for these episodes. video content and so much more, it would be amazing if you would join our Patreon and follow along for the ride. A lot of work and a lot of energy goes into this podcast. It is just me on this
microphone, writing the scripts, putting out the episodes every week. And yeah, I think there's a lot of work that goes into it that's quite unseen. So I kind of wanted to let you guys peek behind the scenes and also offer you guys a chance to get more personal episodes, to be able to ask questions, vote on what episodes you want to hear next, and just build the community, just build the community of loyal listeners, the people who message me and come back week after week to listen. So there will be a link in the description of this episode. It's as cheap as like a dollar a month, but that really does go a long way when a lot of people join in and it helps support me and it helps me. And it helps me keep making quality content. So I would really appreciate if you at least checked it out. And as always,
I am so grateful for the support that you guys show me week in, week out. So I'm just excited for this next chapter. But back to what we are here for today, what we're talking about on today's episode. We're going to discuss how to get ourselves out of a rut. That kind of terrible pit we all find ourselves in from time to time at various points in our lives. We are officially just over halfway through the year and maybe like me, your New Year's resolutions have kind of faded into the background and you're just going through the motions of living, watching the same TV shows, thinking the same thoughts, seeing the same two people and feeling maybe a bit uninspired. Time is kind of passing around us and we may not particularly
feel like we're taking advantage of it. I've been there. In fact, I think that I am there right now. And that's quite unusual for me. These past few weeks, I've been sleeping in, I've been struggling to really articulate my thoughts. The world has just felt really, really bland and tired and cold. And I had this massive cry to my mom about this day. And I just felt so guilty that despite all the freedom that my job permits and the fact that I genuinely get to do what I love every day, I couldn't kind of shake the feeling of feeling really stagnant. And that feeling is so uncomfortable for me. Normally, I'm not someone who can sit still or likes to be inactive or passive in my life. And ironically, I think thinking about that pattern that I've gotten into
really pushed me to write this episode and actually kind of pulled me back into myself a little bit. A rut is by no means a scientific term, but it's a pretty common phrase to describe, I think, a universal experience. It's essentially a period of life where we feel frozen in the motions of everyday living. Everything feels exactly the same. Life feels rather bland. Maybe you're struggling to feel creative or to feel fulfilled. For me, a big sign that I'm in a rut is when I can't really think of anything interesting in my life. Either about the world around me or even myself, you can be in a general rut, which is kind of like an overarching sense that all areas of your life feel kind of bland, but also specifically with a romantic partner, academically with your
career or even around your hobbies or creative pursuits. In psychology, we tend to have a different name for it. It's called dysthemia, which is essentially a milder form of depression, also known as persistent depressive disorder. The symptoms of this disorder typically come and go for a number of years, and they're a lot less severe than a major depressive disorder, but they share a lot of commonalities to our colloquial understanding of what a rut is, emptiness, loss of interest, tiredness, like the colour has somewhat been like drained out of the world. It's a really hard place to be in. But the good news is that if you're feeling a bit stuck at the moment, we are going to
break down exactly why that may be. And more importantly, how to break the cycle. None of us like feeling disappointed in our lives or unhappy. And I think when we get into this state, our set. of stuckness becomes very cyclical and difficult to break out of. So we're going to dive into six tips backed by some of my favorite psychology and theories as to how we can get back to our wonderful, lively, happy selves and kind of take action on where we want to go. We're also going to discuss some of the research behind our shift to full-time work can really trigger a
some of the origins and causes and of course, as always, the significance for our 20s. I feel like this episode is very important. It taught me a lot. I'm definitely in this stage, as I'm sure many of us are. So without further ado, let's get into all the science and the psychology about how you can get out of a rut. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also. and escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed cracks. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations
with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough.
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Lesbian Michael Marincini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. So we already broke down some of the signs that you may be in a rut, but I want to discuss more of what this term actually means for our psychology and our overall mental health and emotional well-being. From a clinical perspective, a rut is essentially a mental downward spiral caused by either an environmental or an internal shift or event where we encounter these.
increasingly negative thoughts about ourselves, about our potential, our future, and that leads to an avoidance of the behaviours and actions that we know will actually make us feel better. It's not so much self-sabotage, but almost this unconscious blindness to the way forward or a sense of very deep apathy around our lives. Part of us acknowledges that we on. not particularly happy. That's why you're listening to this episode. But the other part of our minds is kind of still a bit lost in this mental maze around what to actually do. Here's what that might look like in our lives. So for example, maybe not being able to remember the last time you were truly excited about something, feeling like the days or the months kind of blur together,
getting to the end of the day or the end of the week and having no energy to socialize or to do something fun just wanting to stay in bed feeling an urge to break away from your life maybe fantasizing about moving cities about dropping everything and creating an entirely new identity and life I think deeper than that is this urge to drastically change something in your life this is so strange and random but last week when I was really in this phase I was like convinced that I should shave all my hair off. I was like yeah I'm going to do it and that makes a lot of psychological sense because when we feel stuck or we don't feel in control we want to counteract that by doing something that proves that we are that we do have agency and that kind of shocks the system
in a way. And one of the final signs, real-life signs, is putting off things like your chores or even basic hygiene, feeling an intense fatigue or just interest in the things that used to make you happy. And we can really see the parallels with persistent depressive disorder in some of these symptoms. It's a super unpleasant experience. And often by the time that we actually recognize what's happening, or we can give a word to our experience. It's usually been simmering or going on for a few weeks or even a few months. So I kind of want to examine the origins and the causes of a rut in this next little section. I also think the main thing to really talk about here that perhaps I haven't spoken about is how common it is in our 20s. Perhaps more than we maybe recognize for a number of reasons.
the biggest one is this shift into adulthood and the number of whole new challenges and responsibilities and commitments that are brought on by this stage. The biggest one I've seen in my own life and the lives of those around me is work. The transition from the freedom of our teenage years or even university when everything was really flexible and free to full-time work and structured routine is a huge adjustment that we don't speak about enough. There was this really fascinating study conducted, I think, in 2019, in Norway, of all places, and it found that in the three years between university and the start of our professional lives, young adults like us in their early 20s experienced this increased level of psychological distress.
and with that poorer coping skills and a greater sense of apathy towards their lives. This came down to a few factors, including long working hours, resulting in reduced free time, low job control, but also an effort, reward in balance, whereby we're working these long hours for these very global, depersonalised goals, rather than working towards better and ourselves through education and leisure and hobbies. It's also the existential dread of realizing that this way of living, this monotonous pattern of waking up for work, working inside an office for eight hours, and going home exhausted only to have to do it all over again, that may in fact be our future. So we subsequently have this desire to escape, but also a bit of an emotional
and cognitive shutdown that we associate with being in a rut. It also explains why I think typical rut behavior often involves watching a lot of TV, endless TikTok scrolling, not because we don't have the energy to do other things, but also because of what psychologists call the anxiety, distraction, feedback loop. When we feel uncomfortable feelings like anxiety, but also a sense of hopelessness, We use things like TV or something that gives us an easy dopamine hit to protect us from these feelings. That distraction may be temporarily very soothing, but it often exacerbates our sense of stuckness and our lack of motivation. So if you've recently started full-time work or maybe a new job, that may be an explanation and also shows that you are not alone in this experience.
There are other pretty important causes or triggers as well. Firstly, experiencing a setback or a failure. Following this negative experience, our brains often respond by isolating or pulling back. Maybe a better word for it is hibernating. And we do this as a way to protect our self-esteem from further damage or rejection. What this results in is less new experiences, less enjoyable behaviors or less risk-taking as well. And that subsequently actually worsens rather than improves our mental state.
Our brains need new experiences and stimuli to keep it active. So there is this amazing psychologist who you may have heard about before. Her name is Dr. Laurie Santos. She teaches the course, the Psychology of a Good Life at Yale. And she found that there is a connection between novelty, newness and motivation. Novelty and newness in our world, in our experiences are incredibly rewarding. But when our ego is injured, when we have experienced a setback,
not only do we see a downturn in our overall mood and self-confidence, but also in our receptiveness to new experiences, to seeing friends, to going out, to finding vibrancy in life. and the result of that is getting stuck in this rut-like state. We're going to kind of talk about that neurological relationship a bit more later on because the same reasons we find ourselves in this cycle can kind of also be leveraged to get us out of it. There's another important role that our neurons play in this as well. Routine.
So routines are often really lauded as this like amazing concept, an amazing way to structure our lives. And I think they can be really comforting and safe, but when they become too stiff and too inflexible, they can become quite boring and stifling because our brains repeatedly use the exact same neural pathways and they're not being challenged. So this creates what we call a mental pattern,
and that means that we no longer really have to focus on our lives because we're using the same neural pathways day in and day out. You know, have you ever had those moments where you're driving home from work and then suddenly you're like at your front door and you have absolutely no recollection of your drive home? It's like someone else kind of took over the wheel. That experience is due to this mental pattern and when we fail to challenge that pattern, we become more and more stuck and our brains are less likely to seek new experiences, hence this rut-like feeling, hence this sense of feeling very numb to the world
because you're not actually giving your brain anything new to be excited about. Psychologically, chronic stress is also a massive contributor. I think we need to be especially gentle with ourselves at the moment. the last four years have been a bit of a dumpster fire. And for those of us in our 20s, that like dumpster fire was some of the first years of our adult lives, you know, a global pandemic, a forthcoming recession, war and political and social chaos. And combined with that, we've each gone through the motions of our own lives. We have faced setbacks. We have faced major life transitions. And these global and individual events have what we call a cumulative
effect. And we can eventually face all of the psychological consequences of those events at once. Our brain and body will literally shut us down to protect us. And although it's trying to help, it's trying to do what's right, we get this feeling of stagnation. It can even increase, you know, our likelihood of developing depression, which we know has a lot of links with this kind of rut-like state, with being in a rut. I think the worst thing that we can do in these moments is nothing. And yet, that's all we really want to do. That's the catch-22 of this situation. But if we have been, you know, kind of self-soothing with low effort activities, if we've been allowing failure to isolate us and leave us uninspired if we got stuck in the momentum of doing
nothing, we're actually just going to exacerbate all of the negativity associated with this state. So what I really want to discuss is the tangible actions that we can take to break the cycle. If you were to look this up online, I think a lot of articles will tell you to meditate. They would tell you to engage in self-care. but I want to author something a bit more specific and psychological, but also some things that have really worked in my own experience. I think by listening to this episode, you're kind of already one step closer. So I really want to give you some further kind of strategies and advice and some of the research around what we can do to break out of this state. So all of that
and more in just a second. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we picket here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crime. crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack.
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field
and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
Greg, the lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
This isn't over until Justice. is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. To break out of this cycle, you're going to need to take action. The truth is, I think as we mature, we realize that you're kind of the only one who can really help yourself. That's not to say, reject the help of family and friends, but recognize that at the center
of any change you want to make in your life is you. So we're going to talk through six steps that you can personally instigate to break out of your rut. Whether that takes a few days or a few weeks, it's definitely not forever. And I think enlisting a good number of strategies and having a sense of the path forward is super helpful. So my first tip is to break up the every day with the new. We discussed this before, but neurologically, when we fall into a routine, this can both enable our life and create structure, but if those habits are too constraining,
it can really be quite suffocating. And it can suffocate our space for impulsivity, which at its core is the need for new experiences. Countless studies have shown this, including one in which they found that when people displayed greater exploration or what they called roaming behavior, when they allowed themselves time to be spontaneous, to visit new places, they felt happier,
they felt more motivated. The experience of novelty or going to places you haven't been before actually seemed to have quite a large association in this study with someone's overall sense of satisfaction. And it's not just our happiness, it's not just our life satisfaction, but also our resilience and even our perception of time. One of those big indicators of being in a rut is that time just seems to pass by quite quickly and you have no real memory of what you did during those hours or those days. So this neuroscientist, his name is, I think, Dr. David, Dr. David Eagleman.
And he's focused much of his research on time perception. and he found that novel experiences, they make time pass more slowly. So in effect, this actually makes your life feel longer. I think that's something that we all kind of want. We all want more time. So what I want you to do is to make space in your life two nights a week to do something impulsive and spontaneous. And also, I think a caveat here is not something in front of a screen.
and preferably not something involving alcohol because we know that alcohol not only dims our emotions but also impacts how we consolidate memories. So preferably do something childish, do something silly and fun and new. Me and my house may actually have this list called the Anti-Depression Fun List and we add like all of these random activities to it and pick something from the list to do like once a week or once a fortnight. here are, I'm going to look at the list. Here are some of the ideas that we had. So mini golf, we actually did that the other day. It sounds kind of stupid, but it's actually so much fun. You can go ice skating, go and do a pottery class, a Pilates class, go speed dating,
go to a destruction room. Basically, anything that you would do at like a 12 year old's birthday party except for the speed dating, that would be weird. You should try and do on like a random Wednesday night. Not only does it kind of, I think, encourage you to play, which is just a fantastic thing to practice in itself, but these events are like a circuit breaker for your daily routine. And it also activates parts of your brain that may have been kind of numbed by daily repetitive activities. This links really nicely to my next tip, which is to utilize the healing power of nature. We have been talking about this a lot on the podcast recently, but I stand by it so, so firmly that being outdoors, even just getting 30 minutes of sun or feeling the rain on your face, it offers like a factory reset for your brain and your body when you're in a rut. The science also backs this up. Being in nature increases dopamine and serotonin in our brains, chemicals that are associated with, with an improved sense of satisfaction and motivation.
去一个发泄室。基本上，除了速度约会（那会很奇怪）之外，你会在 12 岁生日派对上做的任何事情，你都应该尝试在某个随意的周三晚上去做。这不仅在某种程度上能鼓励你去玩耍，我认为这本身就是一种非常棒的练习，而且这些活动就像是你日常生活中的一个断路器。它还会激活你大脑中可能被日常重复活动麻木的部分。这与我的下一个建议完美契合，那就是利用大自然的的治愈力量。我们最近在播客里经常讨论这个，但我非常坚定地支持这一点，那就是身处户外，哪怕只是晒 30 分钟太阳，或者感受脸上落下的雨水，当你陷入生活低谷时，它就像是对你大脑和身体的一键恢复出厂设置。科学也证明了这一点。身处大自然会增加我们大脑中的多巴胺和血清素，这些化学物质与提升满足感和动力息息相关。
And that motivation is critical because it's something that we're often missing when we're in a run. Like I said, it's that cycle of knowing that you need to make a change, but having very little energy or inspiration to actually do it. But we can use nature as a way to provide that energy externally. From an evolutionary perspective, our brains have developed to explore. explore our surroundings and to receive various stimuli from our environment. We were meant to be strategic. We were meant to problem solve and also just simply to be outdoors, but in a modern,
这种动力至关重要，因为当我们陷入低谷时，往往最缺乏动力。就像我说的，那是一个循环：你知道自己需要做出改变，但实际上却几乎没有精力和灵感去付诸行动。但我们可以将大自然作为一种外部提供能量的方式。从进化的角度来看，我们的大脑是为了探索而进化的。探索我们周围的环境，并从我们的环境中接收各种刺激。我们注定是具有战略眼光的。我们注定要去解决问题，也注定要简单地去户外面，但在现代，
industrialized, fast-paced society, we have become more and more detached from that innate need. And that level of detachment really disrupts our ability to connect with ourselves. Think about the last time you are actually out in nature, experiencing or enjoying the simple sounds of birds and running water and the wind and the trees, all those beautiful things. If you can't remember the last time you did that, it may be worth contemplating whether you need to reprioritize what's going on in your life to really ground yourself. Grounding is actually also a really valuable exercise now that I think about it. In psychology grounding is this therapeutic technique, I guess, maybe a practice, where you place your bare feet on the earth and you use the natural electrical charge from
工业化、快节奏的社会中，我们与这种天生的需求变得越来越脱节。这种脱节程度实际上扰乱了我们与自己连接的能力。想想你上次真正走到大自然中，体验或享受鸟儿的鸣叫、流水声、风和树木等简单声音是什么时候，所有这些美好的事物。如果你记不清上次这样做是什么时候了，或许值得思考一下，你是否需要重新调整生活中各项事物的优先级，以便真正让自己脚踏实地。说实话，现在我想想，接地气其实也是一个非常有价值的练习。在心理学中，接地气是一种治疗技术，我想，也许是一种练习，你把赤脚踩在大地上，利用来自
the ground to kind of stabilize you and bring you back to the present moment. This may sound weird if you've only, you know, kind of been exposed to Western science and psychology, but many, many, countless indigenous societies across the world have historically used a similar practice to grounding to really treat various ailments, including mental health and mental ailments as well. I would say just give it a go. It can't hurt. And then you can kind of tick two of these practices off your list in one, trying something new and getting out in nature. The next two strategies, I would say is somewhat linked, but they kind of differ in their timelines. Number three is to create one weekly challenge for yourself,
地面的自然电荷来稳定你的情绪，把你带回当下。如果你只接触过西方科学和心理学，这听起来可能有点奇怪，但世界上许多许多无数的原住民社会历史上一直使用类似于接地气的做法来真正治疗各种疾病，包括心理健康和精神疾病。我想说，不妨一试。反正也没什么坏处。然后你就可以一举两得，从清单上划掉两个练习：尝试新事物和走到大自然中。接下来的两个策略，我想说它们在某种程度上有联系，但它们的时间线有所不同。第三个是为你自己制定一个每周挑战，
and number four is to set up small goals and intentions. Let's talk about tip three first. We know that when we're in a rut, it's hard to feel excited about anything. You kind of fantasize about the future without actually doing anything about it. You don't really have a sense of purpose. As a result, I think we don't feel any need to push ourselves beyond our comfort zone or to really do anything at all in our lives.
第四个是设定小目标和意图。我们先来谈谈第三个建议。我们知道，当我们陷入低谷时，很难对任何事情感到兴奋。你会在脑海中幻想未来，却又对此无所作为。你真的没有目标感。结果就是，我认为我们觉得没有必要将自己推向舒适区之外，或者在生活中真正做任何事情。
That is the trap set by being in a rut. Once you fall into it, it's hard to escape because the very things that you could be doing to make yourself feel better are the very things that you feel removed from. This is why the weekly challenge comes in. It doesn't have to be massive. It can be super small, tiny. Just focus on one tangible thing that you can do to make your life better each week. Like leaving the house once a day, walking to work, journaling each night or reading a chapter of a book each night before bed instead of watching TV. These things are manageable.
这就是陷入低谷设下的陷阱。一旦你陷入其中，就很难逃脱，因为那些能让你感觉好起来的事情，正是你觉得自己与之疏远的事情。这就是为什么每周挑战派上了用场。它不必很大。它可以超级小，微不足道。每周只专注于一件你能做到的、让生活变得更好的切实的事情。比如每天出门一次、走路上班、每晚写日记，或者每晚睡觉前读一本书的一章而不是看电视。这些事情都是可以掌控的。
They are small. They're easy to implement. But by setting a weekly challenge and fulfilling it and keeping it and keep. your commitment to yourself, we really build confidence in our own abilities, but also this sense of progress that we may be lacking. It also kind of breaks us away from our normal behavior, that thing that we can become very quickly stuck in and gives us a sense of change, gives us a sense that our lives are not concrete, they're flowing, they're changing, they're different week by week. This also brings me to the next tip, which is to set up
它们很小。它们很容易执行。但通过设定每周挑战并去完成它、坚守它，并信守对自己的承诺，我们不仅增强了对自己能力的信心，还获得了我们可能缺少的这种进步感。它也在某种程度上打破了我们的正常行为，让我们摆脱了那种很快就会陷入其中的泥潭，并给我们带来了一种改变感，让我们觉得生活不是一成不变的，而是流动的、变化的，每周都有所不同。这也让我想到了下一个建议，那就是建立
small goals and intentions for yourself that give you something to look forward to but also to strive towards the weekly challenge is obviously going to change each week but the short-term goals are going to require a bit more effort but i think with that comes a bit more reward often one of the reasons we find ourselves stuck in a rut is because of all or nothing thinking around what we want to achieve and the direction of our lives, particularly in our 20s. We talk about the quarter life crisis quite a bit on this show, but really our 20s are such a season of feeling lost and stuck. And I think the only thing worse than doing something and maybe failing is doing nothing at all. We also have this tendency, I think, like I said, to engage in all or nothing thinking,
为你自己设定小目标和意图，让你有所期待，并为之奋斗。每周挑战显然每周都会改变，但短期目标需要付出更多努力，但我认为随之而来的是更多回报。通常，我们发现自己陷入低谷的原因之一，是对我们想要实现的目标以及生活方向（尤其是在我们二十多岁的时候）抱有全有或全无的思维方式。我们在节目中经常讨论四分之一人生危机，但实际上，二十多岁确实是一个感到迷茫和困惑的时期。而且我认为，比做某事却可能失败更糟糕的事情，就是什么都不做。我认为，我们也有这种倾向，正如我所说，陷入全有或全无的思维模式，
where we think the only option is success or failure. And we create these huge lofty ambitions. And when we face setbacks, when we face struggles, we kind of give up because we're thinking only about the end goal. And we also know from earlier research that failure increases these rut-like feelings as well. So by breaking things down into smaller goals, rather than these huge lofty ambitions that are a lot easier to fail at, we're better able to be consistent, but also stay motivated.
我们认为唯一的选择就是成功或失败。我们树立了这些宏大崇高的抱负。当我们面对挫折、当我们面对挣扎时，我们就会放弃，因为我们只想着最终目标。我们也从先前的研究中得知，失败也会增加这些类似低谷的感觉。因此，与其设立那些极易失败的宏大崇高抱负，不如将事情分解为更小的目标，这样我们就能更好地保持连贯性，也能保持动力。
And that also helps in getting us out of this place of stagnation because we provide ourselves with the external motivation of something to focus on, which takes us out of our minds and out of our self-pity into a space where we feel ready to take action. You don't need to run a marathon tomorrow, but maybe sign up for a 5K in three months. That gives you enough time. Looking forward to something, giving you a sense of the future, giving you a sense of purpose, those things are all really valuable in counteracting this negative loop. Let's also talk about setting intentions.
这也有助于我们摆脱这种停滞不前的状态，因为我们为自己提供了某种可以关注的事物的外部动力，这让我们摆脱了胡思乱想和自怜自艾，进入一个随时准备采取行动的状态。你明天不需要去跑马拉松，但也许可以报名参加三个月后的 5 公里长跑。这给了你足够的时间。期待某事，给你一种对未来的期盼，给你一种目标感，这些在对抗这种消极循环时都非常有价值。我们再来谈谈设定意图。
I started setting monthly intentions, I think like a few months back, maybe six months ago. and it doesn't mean that I don't still experience temporary low moments and stuckness, but when I am in those moments, it does give me something to kind of center myself. It's really simple. It's super simple. It's like a list-like process. What I want to ask you is, what are four things that you can do in the next month that you'll be proud you did in four weeks time?
我开始设定每月的意图，我想大概是几个月前，也许是六个月前。这并不意味着我仍然不会经历短暂的低谷和停滞不前的时刻，但当我处于这些时刻时，它确实能给我一些让我集中精神的东西。这真的很简单。超级简单。它就像一个类似清单的过程。我想问你的是，在接下来的一个月里，你可以做哪四件事，让你在四周后为自己感到骄傲？
how do you want your life to move forward in the next month? And write them down somewhere permanent. I like to put them above my desk so that I get that reminder. You can also put it as an alert on your phone. You can set them as your alarm text. In the words of this really amazing mindfulness coach, intention setting is empowering because instead of feeling like a victim of circumstance, you become the conscious creator of your life.
在接下来的一个月里，你希望你的生活如何向前发展？把它们写在某个永久的地方。我喜欢把它们贴在我的办公桌上方，这样我就能得到提醒。你也可以把它设为手机提醒。你可以把它们设为闹钟文字。用这位非常了不起的正意念教练的话来说，设定意图是赋予力量的，因为你不再觉得自己是环境的受害者，而是成为了自己生活的有意识的创造者。
And that's something we often feel separated from. The thoughts you have become your actions. And the thoughts you have about your life become your life. So starting internally with that mindset shift, even the simple action of just writing down four things that you can do is super powerful. My next tip is definitely a personal favorite, and it's one that not many people I've seen have spoken about. It has to do with creativity. You need to do something creative, even if you're terrible at it, even if you suck.
而这正是我们经常感到与之隔离的东西。你的想法变成了你的行动。你对生活的想法决定了你的生活。因此，从内在开始，改变这种心态，甚至仅仅写下你可以做的四件事这个简单的动作，都具有超强的威力。我的下一个建议绝对是个人最爱，而且是我见过的没多少人谈论过的一个建议。它与创造力有关。你需要做一些有创造力的事，即使你很不擅长，即使你做得很烂。
Just make something, anything. And here's why that's important when you're stuck in a rut and why it's made it onto this list. Creating something gives us purpose because it feels productive, and tangible, which in turn kind of imbues our life with a sense of meaning. So many of our ideas and our visions for life, our plans, are very intangible and internal. But when we create something we can hold and touch and produce, this shows us that there is actually something in the world that we have agency over. There is something that we can create.
去创造点什么，任何东西都行。以下是为什么当你陷入低谷时这很重要，以及为什么它能进入这个清单的原因。创造一些东西能给我们带来目标感，因为它让人觉得富有成效且切实可行，这反过来又给我们的生活注入了一种意义感。我们的许多想法、对生活的愿景以及计划，都是非常无形和内在的。但当我们创造出我们可以握住、触摸和产出的东西时，这就向我们表明，世界上确实有我们可以掌控的东西。有些事情是我们能够创造的。
we can put good things into this planet, into this world, into the people around us. Scientifically and psychologically, there's also this idea called the theory of cognition, which essentially tells us that being creative is one of the bases of human life. Everything rests on our ability to create. And beyond that, it also increases happiness. It creates a flow-like meditative state. creativity reduces dementia and improves mental health, mainly by helping us to manage our negative emotions in a productive way. That is really the crux of this. All of these benefits act as
我们可以把美好的事物带给这个星球、这个世界、以及我们身边的人。在科学和心理学上，还有一个叫做认知理论的概念，它基本上告诉我们，创造力是人类生命的基础之一。一切都依赖于我们的创造能力。除此之外，它还能增加幸福感。它能创造一种心流般的冥想状态。创造力可以减少痴呆症并改善心理健康，主要是通过帮助我们以富有成效的方式管理负面情绪。这才是关键所在。所有这些好处都起到了
protective factors against falling into a rut. Also, I think when we're in this state, it almost physically feels like our brains are just a lot slower and somewhat incapable of thinking. smart or interesting things. So when we take time to actually be creative and to tap into that area of our brain that has kind of been left dormant, we do see a huge difference. You know, make terrible doodles, make a chunky scarf, an ugly painting. Whatever you need to do, I think creativity really unlocks different neural pathways. It unlocks different ways of seeing the world. It breaks us out of the very kind of stale existence that often accompanies full-time work and full-time study and daily routines. Finally, tip number six, hold yourself accountable for the changes you want to make in your life.
抵御陷入低谷的保护因素。此外，我认为当我们处于这种状态时，从身体感觉上来说，我们的大脑似乎要慢得多，某种程度上无法思考聪明或有趣的事情。因此，当我们花时间真正去发挥创造力并触及大脑中沉睡的那部分区域时，我们确实看到了巨大的不同。你知道，画一些糟糕的涂鸦，织一条厚重的围巾，画一幅丑陋的画。无论你需要做什么，我认为创造力确实能开启不同的神经通路。它开启了看待世界的不同方式。它让我们打破了全职工作、全职学习和日常生活常常伴随的那种陈旧的生存状态。最后，第六条建议，为你想要在生活中做出的改变承担责任。
I say this all the time, but the easiest thing to do is what is most convenient. And that urge to do nothing to keep spending our days in bed or watching television is particularly pronounced when we're in a rut, and sometimes we cannot be the only person in our lives trying to hold ourselves accountable for change. I would really encourage you to tell your friends or your family, people who are around you often. I think any problem spoken out loud is immediately halved, and chances are they're probably going to say something like, yeah, hey, me too, or like I've been there before, but also you can kind of use your friends to help you achieve things like your weekly challenges or your fun nights out.
我一直在说这个，但最容易做的事就是最方便的事。那种什么都不做、继续把日子花在床上或看电视的冲动，在我们陷入低谷时尤其明显，有时我们可能无法成为我们生活中唯一试图为改变承担责任的人。我真的鼓励你告诉你的朋友或家人，也就是经常在你身边的人。我认为任何大声说出来的问题都会立刻减半，他们很可能会说“是啊，嘿，我也是”或者“我以前也经历过”，而且你还可以借助朋友来帮助你实现诸如每周挑战或有趣的夜生活之类的事情。
Get them involved. Bring them over for an art night. Ask them to start running with you. Whatever it is that's going to break this cycle, when you feel like you're not alone, but also when you feel like you'll disappoint someone else if you don't commit or follow through, most of the time you're more likely to succeed. It's such a strange. conundrum, like this really strange, like human idiosyncrasy, that we are more concerned
让他们参与进来。邀请他们过来举办一个艺术之夜。请他们开始和你一起跑步。无论是什么能打破这个循环的事情，当你觉得自己并不孤单，而且当你觉得如果不坚持或贯彻到底就会让别人失望时，大多数情况下你更有可能成功。这是一个多么奇怪的难题，就像这种非常奇怪的人类特性，我们更关心的
about letting others down than letting ourselves down. But we can leverage that instinct to kind of get moving and to do things. And also telling friends means that they'll be more inclined to check in and see how you're going and provide you with that encouragement, which I think every human really needs any emotional state that's distressing or negative, even just feeling like you're in a bit of a rut, I really honestly do believe that when other people know when you invite them into your struggles, it becomes a lot easier to manage. Enlisting those six strategies, I think we'll get you back to a place where you're feeling more like yourself.
是让别人失望，而不是让自己失望。但我们可以利用这种本能去行动并完成事情。而且告诉朋友意味着他们会更倾向于关心你的近况，看你过得怎么样，并给你那种鼓励，我认为每个人在任何痛苦或消极的情绪状态下，甚至只是感觉自己陷入了一点低谷时，真的都非常需要这种鼓励。我真的由衷地相信，当别人知道你的挣扎并你邀请他们参与其中时，事情就会变得容易掌控得多。我认为，只要运用这六个策略，就能让你回到感觉更像自己的状态。
I don't think I can promise an overnight shift, but in a few weeks, it will be hard not to see a change, not just in your motivation and your happiness, but your overall mindset. I feel a lot of empathy for those of us really, you know, grinding it out at uni or at work and just feeling really devoid of a sense of self. But I also don't think that that experience is uncommon. I think it's very natural to go through period. where we lose a bit of our spark, we lose a bit of our sense of self, like I said. But what I always think is that if you don't change something now, it's going to be a lot harder
我不认为我能承诺一夜之间的转变，但在几周内，你很难看不到变化，不仅在你的动力和幸福感方面，而且在你的整体心态方面。我对于我们当中那些真正在大学或工作中苦苦挣扎、感觉自己完全失去自我意识的人感到非常同理。但我也认为这种经历并不少见。我认为经历失去一点火花、失去一点自我意识（就像我说的）的时期是非常自然的。但我总是觉得，如果你现在不改变某些事情，以后会难得多
to change it in five or ten years. So I'm sending you a lot of love and strength. It's not forever. You've got the strategies. And I do just really hope that this episode has helped you out. Also, you know, around happiness and things like that, I think We really are in control of our own happiness. And sometimes we don't realize that even small things that feel like a lot of effort and feel like a lot of energy make a sizable difference. Five minutes setting your intentions, five minutes doing something impulsive, five minutes doing a little doodle, talking to a friend. Sometimes we don't think that that will help, but it really does. So it's not to say you need to make huge changes in your life.
在五年或十年后去改变它。所以我向你们发送了大量的爱和力量。这不是永远的。你已经有了这些策略。我真的希望这一集能对你有所帮助。此外，关于幸福之类的事情，我认为我们确实掌控着自己的幸福。有时我们没有意识到，即使是那些感觉需要付出很多努力和精力的微小事情，也能带来巨大的改变。花五分钟设定意图，花五分钟做一件冲动的事，花五分钟画一个小涂鸦，跟朋友聊聊天。有时我们不认为这会有帮助，但它确实有。所以这并不是说你需要在生活中做出巨大的改变。
I just think that small daily practices, daily things, daily intentions really do bring us back to who we are and who we want to be and allow us to kind of break out of this cycle. So I really do hope that this episode helped you out. You're not alone in your rut. I'm with there with you right now. And if you have a friend who maybe needs to hear this episode, as always, I would really appreciate it if you shared it along. Maybe it will help them out.
我只是认为，日常的小实践、日常的事情、日常的意图确实能让我们回到我们是谁、我们想成为谁，并让我们能够打破这个循环。所以我真的希望这一集对你有所帮助。你在低谷中并不孤单。我现在就在那里陪着你。如果你有一个朋友可能需要听听这一集，一如既往，如果你能分享出去，我将不胜感激。也许这会对他们有所帮助。
and you'll be able to recognize that there are other people going through this as well. As always, if you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify. Wherever you are listening right now, it helps the show to grow and reach new people. And again, if you like this content, if you want more content like this, if you want bonus content, unreleased episodes, episode transcripts, studies, newsletters, all that good stuff, please check out my Patreon. I will leave a link in the description of this episode.
你也会意识到还有其他人也在经历这一切。一如既往，如果你喜欢这一集，请随时在 Apple Podcasts、Spotify 上留下五星好评。无论你现在在哪里收听，这都有助于节目的成长并接触到新的人。再说一次，如果你喜欢这个内容，如果你想要更多这样的内容，如果你想要独家内容、未发布的剧集、剧集文稿、研究报告、新闻简报所有这些好东西，请查看我的 Patreon。我会在本集的描述中留下链接。
It really does support me as someone who is doing this very independently and doing this very much on my own. It's great to see the community grow and hopefully you'll go and check it out. If you have an episode suggestion, follow me at that psychology podcast. I read them all. They are so amazing. I often integrate what you're going through. into my episodes so I really do love to hear from other people in their 20s or of any age who
这确实对我这个非常独立、非常靠自己做这件事的人提供了支持。看到这个社区的成长真是太棒了，希望你会去看看。如果你有剧集建议，请在那个心理学播客关注我。我都读了。它们太棒了。我经常把我所经历的融入到我的剧集中，所以我真的很喜欢听听其他二十多岁或任何年龄段的人的意见
have an experience that they want to understand the psychology so thank you again for listening along and we will be back next week with another episode. Hey, what's good y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This speech is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional. who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit are armored. It signals to the world that you not to be played with.
他们有想要理解心理学的经历，所以再次感谢您的收听，我们下周将带着另一集回归。嘿，大家好！你们正在收听的是由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加姆斯主持的《难忘的教训》。这段演讲是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都不太安全但却极为坦诚的对话，而你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着西装，带着盔甲。这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，请在 AHA 广播应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《难忘的教训》。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。
And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters
在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健康和构建弹性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一边成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即在 IHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 TWA%。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们采取了行动
into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
亲自动手。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。在 IHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。
On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors, like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year.
在《回顾过去》播客中。从 1979 年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。84 年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会选择一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过那段时光的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的人以及最喜欢的作家一起，比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论 80 年代。那是一个疯狂的年份。
It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在 IHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。这是一个 IHeart 播客。保证是人类制作的。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。